[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Container Registry
is a private container image
registry that runs
on Google Cloud.
This quickstart shows you
how to build a Docker image
and how to push and pull the
image from your project's
Container Registry, all
from the command line.
Before you begin, make sure
that, one, you have a Google
Cloud project
selected; two, building
and the Container Registry
API are enabled; and three,
you have the Cloud
SDK and Docker
installed on your system.
For this quickstart,
we'll use Docker
to create a container
image of a small Python web
app, which we will then
push to Container Registry.
To create the
Docker image, create
a directory with three files.
One, the Docker file,
which provides information
on how to package
the application.
Two, requirements.txt is
used to list your application
and dependencies.
Three, app.py is the
actual Python code
of your application.
Run the Docker Build command
to create a Docker image
on your local machine.
Next, we'll configure Docker
to use the gcloud command line
tool to authenticate requests
to Container Registry using
the gcloud auth command.
Now we'll use the Docker Tag
command to associate the Docker
image with a registry name
so that we can push the image
to a specific location.
We can now upload
the Docker image
to Container Registry with
the Docker Push command.
You can view images hosted
by Container Registry
via the Google Cloud
console or by visiting
the image's registry
name in your web browser.
To pull the image from
Container Registry
onto your local machine,
run the Docker Pull command.
Finally, you can
delete the Docker image
from Container Registry using
the gcloud container images
Delete command.
[MUSIC PLAYING]